- [Voiceover] So we're asked,
Is the expression x minus three,
is this a factor of this
fourth degree polynomial?
And you could solve this by
doing algebraic long division
by taking all of this business
and dividing it by x minus three
and figuring out if you have a remainder.
If you do end up with a remainder
then this is not a factor of this.
But if you don't have a
remainder then that means
that this divides fully
into this right over here
without a remainder which
means it is a factor.
So if the remainder is equal to zero,
the remainder is equal to zero,
if and only if,
it's a factor.
It is a factor.
And we know a very fast way
of calculating the remainder
of when you take some polynomial
and you divide it by a first
degree expression like this.
I guess you could say when you divide it
by a first degree polynomial like this.
The polynomial remainder theorem,
the polynomial remainder theorem tells us
that if we take some polynomial, p of x
and we were to divide it by some x minus a
then the remainder is
just going to be equal to
our polynomial evaluated at
our polynomial evaluated at a.
So let's just see what's a in this case.
Well in this case our a is positive three.
So let's just evaluate our
polynomial at x equals 3,
if what we get is equal to zero
that means our remainder is zero
and that means that x
minus three is a factor.
If we get some other remainder
that means well we have
a non-zero remainder
and this isn't a factor,
so let's try it out.
So, we're gonna have,
so I'm just gonna do it all in magenta.
It might be a little
computationally intensive.
So it's going to be two times
three to the fourth power,
three to the fourth, three
to (mumbles), that's 81.
81.
Minus 11
Yeah, this is gonna get a
little computationally intensive
but let's see if we can power through it.
11 times 27,
I probably should have
picked a simpler example,
but let's just keep going.
Plus 15 times nine.
Plus four times three is 12.
Minus 12
So lucky for us, at least those
last two terms cancel out.
And so this is going to be
the rest from here is arithmetic.
Two times 81 is 162.
Now let's think about what 27 times 11 is.
So let's see, 27 times
10 is going to be 270.
270 plus another 27 is minus 297.
297, did I do that, yeah, 270
So 27 times 10 is 270 plus 27, 297
Yep, that's right.
And then we have,
I'm prone to make careless errors here,
see 90 plus 45 is 135.
So plus 135.
And let's see,
if I were to take
if I were to take 162 and 135,
that's going to give me 297
minus 297.
Minus 200, we do it in that green color,
And we do indeed equal zero.
So the remainder,
if I were to divide this by this,
is equal to zero.
So x minus three is indeed a factor
of all of this business.